the last two big talk shows that you
appeared on was Don Lemon on CNN and
Tucker Carlson and they both were fired
you know hours after appearing on uh
having you as a guest
um to talk about this identity crisis
and about kind of bringing people
together can we run let's run that uh
clip Zach that you have of the Don Lemon
discussion because I think this comes to
bear on these questions of national
identity Vivek and what you're putting
at the at the foreground of your um
presidential run so let's look at this
clip real quick and let me just note
that this is uh you know edited down for
time but we have the links to everything
in the description
yeah we fought a Civil War in this
country to give black Americans the
equal protection under the law that we
fail to secure them in 1776.
but then you want to know what happened
Southern States passed anti-gun laws
that stopped black people from owning
guns the Democrat Party then as in now
wanted to put them back in chains that
war was not fought for black people to
have guns that's that's not that war was
brought for black people to have
freedoms in this country actually that's
why the Civil War was fought okay
for black people to have guns I think
actually you know funny fact is black
people did not get to enjoy the other
freedoms until their second amendment
rights were secured and I think that
that's one of the lessons that we aren't
allowed to enjoy the freedoms I disagree
with you on that Don I disagree with you
on it I think you're doing a disservice
to our country by failing to recognize
and then you live in this country then
you can disagree with me but we're not
well here's where you and I have a
different point of view I think we
should be able to express our views
regardless of the color of our skin we
should have this debate without me
regarding
I'll tell you I am I'm an Indian
American I'm proud of it but I think we
should have this debate black white
doesn't matter
do it you should do it in an honest way
uh and let's note that according to the
New York Times this might have been one
of the last straws for Don Lemon they uh
right here that the incident left
several CNN leaders exasperated so just
before we get into the substance of your
disagreement with Don Lemon there what's
your reaction to his dismissal
I mean look I think that depends on the
mission of your organization if the
mission of your organization is to
foster a particular worldview in this
case a woke world view and to advance
that that's a perfectly legitimate we
live in a free country you're allowed to
start an Enterprise where that's your
purpose Don Lemon would make a great
host but if your State admission of your
organization is what Chris licked the
new CEO of CNN says their mission is is
to Foster diverse viewpoints and
actually engage in the prevails of news
and opinions that are diverse in nature
on your programs that Don Lemon would
not be a good host if he shouts down
guests on the base of the color of their
skin saying they can't make those
arguments and you didn't have the
segment where he was also shouting it as
producers and preventing as a co-host
from getting into the conversation so it
depends on what the mission of your
organization is CNN has stated its
missions I think it would be very
consistent with that mission for them to
find a better Anchor than Don Lemon so
I'm happy to have played the final role
in squeezing uh the lemonade out of the
lemon and and you know moving on with it
so I think more debates what we need
what's your pitch to Black America
um though because you know most blacks
are you know blacks the the share of
black votes that went to the GOP went up
a little bit under Trump in the second
term but you know basically since
Eisenhower in his second term you know
it's rare when a when a republican
candidate can get 10 of the black vote
um you know what's your pitch to Black
America and I was just asking about for
a new national identity yes so the first
thing I would say is I don't view there
as being one Black America just like
there's no one white America or one
Indian American America I reject that
premise at the outset but you know how
why do we take a look at this
demographic that tends to vote Democrat
I think a big part of the problem is
Republicans have not explained what our
intentions are and I say our I mean I'm
I'm an America First conservative I am
using the Republican party as a vehicle
to advance my set of ideals I'm very
open about that I'm not a partisan
politician or hack I could care less for
political partisanship most of it bores
me but we're playing the game of
presidential politics let's talk about
the Republican Party
I think let's look at the facts I mean
Lyndon Johnson created a so-called Great
Society it's the biggest misnomer in
modern political history that wasn't a
very great society for the very black
people it was supposed to help
paid mothers government money to have an
incentive to get the dad out of the
house so they could make more money
Uncle Sam's better for me than you over
here maybe I'll marry him instead so how
you get to over 70 of black kids being
born into two parent households in the
1960s to less than 30 percent today you
get what you pay for is the answer to
that and I think it's in a front I don't
think that's been good for black
Americans across the country that isn't
it also true the breeze I mean you know
and I I'm thinking of somebody like
Jackie Robinson who in 1960 campaigned
for Richard Nixon in 1964 campaigned for
Democrats because Republicans voted
against the Civil Rights Act and the
Voting Rights Act of the mid-60s when
much of the country was still under
legal segregation where it was illegal
to serve blacks and whites equally it
was illegal for blacks to go to certain
schools and things like that and it
strikes me as you know kind of if you
start the clock in 1968 or 1972 it's one
thing but
um you know this I mean I think this is
part of Republican problem with an
appeal to Black Americans is that yeah I
mean that's ancient history at this
point no it is literally if you're
talking about you know Lyndon Johnson
you know we're talking about the 60s
embarrassing yeah 64. fair enough you
know I I was talking about Lyndon
Johnson because many of those policies
are still in effect today right Civil
Rights Act did pass and there's broad
consensus in favor of the Civil Rights
Acts today I think that there's there
should not be in my opinion broad
consensus around the vestiges of Lyndon
Johnson's Great Society so that's a
distinction I draw I mean the Republican
party is the party that was the
Abolitionist party and the pro in the
post Reconstruction Era also wanted to
put guns in the household of black
Americans so they could actually secure
the civil rights as I was talking about
in that clip so go back and these
parties like I said these labels mean
very little if you go far enough back
party's a flip-flop but what I say is
that the policies I care about want to
go to the root causes restore the
nuclear family structure as a cultural
norm in this country including in Black
America restore focus on education
school choice is a big part of this
empowering many black families that are
trapped in ghetto-like communities for
their kids to be trapped in those
schools and I use that word
intentionally to provoke the point that
we're really confining people to the
public school systems where they live
without school choice programs Democrats
are the ones who are opposed to school
choice programs right that was the
reason live stream with Vivek ramaswamy
who's running for the Republican
nomination for president and has just
published capitalist punishment A Book
Like diatribe against ESG and other
aspects of what he considers woke
capitalism if you want to watch the full
conversation go here if you want to
watch another excerpt go here and come
back next Thursday every Thursday at 1
pm when Zach wise Miller and I are
talking to somebody even more
interesting than the last week thanks
for watching